es el más reciente texto del gobierno
macrón dedicado al medio ambiente la
asamblea nacional inicia el examen del
proyecto de ley de clima y resiliencia
la ministra de ecología defendió su
contenido el domingo spitzer el espíritu
del proyecto de ley de clima resiliencia
es llevar la ecología a la vida
cotidiana de los franceses dar a los
franceses los medios para poder ser
ambientalistas se suponía que la ley
retomaría a las 149 propuestas hechas
por la convención ciudadana para el
clima pero al final sólo se
seleccionaron 10 un texto considerado
insuficiente por el consejo superior del
clima así como por un centenar de
organizaciones
el texto no permite reducir nuestras
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en un 40 por ciento para 2030 y menos
aún a alcanzar el nuevo objetivo europeo
de reducción del 55% mientras que la
ciencia recomienda una reducción del 65%
asociaciones partidos y sindicatos piden
medidas mucho más drásticas en muchos
ámbitos como la renovación térmica de
los edificios la regulación de la
publicidad de productos contaminantes la
opción de un menú vegetariano
obligatorio en los catering colectivos o
la eliminación de enlaces aéreos cuando
la duración de un viaje no supere las
dos horas y media en tren los diputados
han presentado unas siete mil enmiendas
para la consideración del proyecto de
ley el debate se llevará a cabo durante
tres semanas sin embargo los
ambientalistas consideran ese tiempo
demasiado corto dada la emergencia
climática global